so as we continue my series on the Iron
Man armors from the Marvel movies we
pick up now with March 11 through 45 the
however because models 15 through 41
functioned as part of the iron Legion
and were only seen as one offs
information on most of these seats is
virtually non-existent but there are a
few models we can pay special attention
to since their purpose was unique from
the standard fare of Iron Man armors
[Music]
beginning with a mark 15 codenamed
sneaky this suit was the first model
developed by stark for the purpose of
espionage and stealth it created after
the Battle of New York during the
Avengers the mark 15 was a hodgepodge of
technology found in military-grade
stealth equipment and circuitry of
Starks own design in terms of his
weaponry this suit maintained the
standard load out of repulsors a unibeam
and jets on the boots for flight but
also used an anti radar detection system
as well as camouflaging technology using
the physical design of the suit to
reflect light the mark 15 was capable of
modifying the chrome exterior to
virtually any color allowing the suit to
blend in with his environment making it
virtually invisible to the human eye in
addition to this the armor contained
stealth dampeners designed to reduce
energy output and sound when maneuvering
moving on to the mark 16 codenamed
nightclub much like the 15 this suit was
designed for stealth but also offered
improvements on the previous model while
the mark 13 remained hidden from radar
due to its minimal radar crosshair the
mark 16 contain actual cloaking
technology capable of rendering the suit
completely invisible to any and all
forms of radar detection however while
the mark 16 did contain a stripped-down
version of the standard loadout for Iron
Man armors a byproduct of this advanced
design was that the armor did not
contain the titanium alloy of its
contemporaries and instead returned to a
lightweight metallic alloy as a result
the suit was extremely fragile in
comparison to other models and was
quickly destroyed during Stark's battle
with Aldrich Killian transitioning to
the mark 37 codenamed hammerhead this
suit was the first designed for deep sea
travel now something to point out here
is that all of the Iron Man suits are
capable of functioning underwater at
full capacity with minimal issue the
difference between this model and other
versions is the depth at which it
travels because the pressure in the
deepest part of the oceans has the same
impact on the human body as a normal
person to me to hold out 50 jumbo jets
the mark 37 was designed to be capable
to withstand these extreme pressure
while operating at full capacity as a
result the suit possesses a shorter
stockier appearance than other models
and was outfitted with several layers of
high-grade reinforced armor making it
virtually indestructible by conventional
weapons moving on to the mark 38 also
known as a he wore this suit was
designed by stark for heavy lifting but
also functioned as an after-the-fact
precursor to Hulkbuster designed to
withstand weights up to several tons the
MUC 38 did not possess the standard load
out of repulsors a unibeam in flight
instead this suit possessed a reinforced
titanium alloy a combined with several
metallic alloys functioning as
reinforcement armor as well as
specialized Pistons in the legs and
ankles in order to support the weight of
heavier objects while still maintaining
maneuverability picking up at the mark
42 this suit removes us from the iron
Legion of March 15 through 41 which were
all destroyed at the end of Iron Man 3
and returns us to suits worn by Tony
Stark himself while this model did
appear prior to the iron Legion in Iron
Man 3 its debut came during the manors
attack on Starks home during which time
Tony had the suit bond itself to pepper
in order to save her life
well the events would see start use the
suit himself after Pepper was taken to
safety the model was destroyed during
the battle with aldrich killian after
the suit self-destruction mechanism had
been activated by Jarvis in terms of his
weaponry this suit was designed to be
one-of-a-kind in that unlike all
previous Ironman models that require
start to physically step into the suit
the mark 42 was cybernetically linked to
stark by way of computer chips in his
arms giving him the ability to suit
himself or others in the armor with
satellites usable as backup
communications devices should start the
outside of the suits normal
communication range in addition to this
the mark 42 maintain the portability of
the March 5 and 7 while keeping the
titanium alloy seen in the mark 4 going
forward as well as a standard fare of
repulsors a unibeam a one-shot particle
laser and flight maneuverability getting
into the mark 43 this suit was designed
by Starck following the clean slate
protocol of Iron Man 3 the destruction
of all previous Iron Man armors and
Tony's desire to start over again
debuting in Avengers 2 age of Ultron the
monk 42 was used in the first several
conflicts against the Hydra base of
Baron von Strucker as well as the
conflict in Wakanda against ulysses klaw
Ultron Quicksilver and the Scarlet Witch
regarding his weaponry the month 43
contained the standard load out of
normal Ironman weapons but also contains
several new abilities the
voice-activated sentry mode allowed
start to position the armor to serve as
a garnish sorts during exploratory
missions the infrared scanner allowed to
start to physically see through walls
and track enemies as well as possessing
anti-tank missiles a shoulder-mounted
minigun and fortress infiltrator
missiles however the true feat of the
mark 43 came in two forms the core suit
and the autonomic prehensile propulsion
technologies regarding appt this allowed
stark to equipment aspect of the suit
like a glove but it can also be assumed
that he would be capable of taking on
any other part onto himself with the
armor still maintaining its entry
program and operating at maximum
capacity this allowed to start to
physically dawn other armors on top of
the bar 43 for the purpose of battling
more difficult enemies while still being
100% effective should the outer armor be
destroyed
getting into the mark 44 codename
Hulkbuster or Veronica unlike the comics
this suit was designed as a joint
venture between 20 stark and Bruce
Banner explicitly to battle Bruce in his
hook form standing at 24 feet in height
from head to toe making it 12 feet
taller than the Hulk much like the
comics the Hulkbuster armor served as an
add-on to existing Iron Man suits in
terms of its weaponry the Hulkbuster
armor is equipped with 11 arc reactors
in order to power its capabilities which
include the standard load out of
repulsors a uni-beam and a micro country
repeater all of which are vastly more
powerful owing to the multitude of arc
reactors in the armor however because
the suit was designed to physical
hand-to-hand combat and maneuverability
instead of stealth or speed the
Hulkbuster was designed to possess a
level of strength and durability beyond
banners base form allowing the suit to
subdue banner as quickly as possible
before his level of anger and strength
exceeded the defensive and offensive
capabilities of the suit moving on the
Lamarck 45 this suit was designed as a
follow-up to the marks 43 and 44 were
debuted in the final conflict between
Ultron and the Avengers at sokovia
proper while the armor is for all
intensive purposes identical to the
previous models there are several
features which allow the suit to stand
out that gives his contemporaries chief
among them is at the mark 45 is the
first suit to be designed completely out
of vibranium making it the most
physically durable honor so far
in addition to this because the Jarvis
AI was transferred into the body of
vision following his activation start
develop the Friday AI as a replacement
which functions in a fashion identical
to Jarvis in the older suits regarding
us weaponry the mark 45 maintains the
repulsors unibeam sentry mode infrared
scan II and prehensile systems of the
mark 43 but also incorporates the energy
and strength capabilities of the
Hulkbuster suit making the mark 45
stronger and more powerful and more
agile than Hulkbuster in addition to
this the mark 45 sees the return of the
one-shot particle laser found in
previous models but in a more improved
form allowing the laser to be fired
continuously for as long as it suits
armor remains powered with that being
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end because that gets us caught up to
civil war and I am very excited but
anyway let me know what you guys think
about these videos did you guys enjoy
them I'll tell you about doing one on
Captain America's shield let me know how
you guys feel about that and I will
catch you guys later peace